so today I want to talk to you about the
annoying process of mastering a skill
ever wonder why so few people master a
skill said I want you to think about
this for a moment right have you ever
seen somebody maybe it could be their
golf swing maybe you could be somebody
shooting a basketball or it could be
somebody's baseball swing or whatever it
could be and they make it seem so easy
and just like so you know as if they're
not even putting any effort into it it's
an effortless type of thing they're
doing and then you go out there and do
it as an amateur and it looks nothing
like what that person did now once you
think about this here I want you to
think about the first time you did
anything whatever it could be think
creative go to the first time you did
that thing yes the thing you're thinking
about how embarrassing were you at doing
that first time of whatever that thing
is you know that remember the first time
how bad was it
how embarrassing was it I mean I think
about the first time I did a lot of
things my goodness if there was a video
of it I'd be laughing all day long if I
could watch how terrible I was in it and
why do so few of us master things well
last week I had the opportunity of
spending some time with an instructor
golf instructor Michael and he and I
were sitting down and having a
conversation together and he said you
know the game of golf is very annoying
and very frustrating I said Tommy tell
me why he says well because you're it's
gone an 80 mile an hour swing and you're
supposed to hit the small ball and all
the small little angles could dictate
which direction the ball is gonna go so
you couldn't really drive yourself nuts
so I said when does one really start
enjoying the game of golf I wanted to
hear his answer listen to what he told
me he said one learns and enjoys the
game of golf when you know why the ball
went where it went
I said elaborate he said as an amateur
you get up then you try to hit the ball
you miss the ball right if you make a
contact and goes right or goes left it
goes all over the place and you're how
come I went to that place he says once
you learn why the ball is going to the
right and why the ball is going to the
left you get to actually enjoy because
your next swing you just make a minor
adjustment
maybe it's your shoulders maybe it's
your back not being straight maybe your
head's moving more than two or three
inches maybe your weight is on your
heels instead of your toes 70/30 maybe
you're not 60/40 on your back but maybe
you're the balls not aligned the right
with which our left foot if you're
getting to drive or all of these things
you think about he says but once you
figure that out you actually get a
chance to enjoy the game and I said you
know what that's exactly what it is to
be an entrepreneur and a businessman you
know you sit there and you wonder why is
this thing not working for me and you
know typically what it is in business
it's one small minor adjustment you got
to make em boom you start enjoying the
game again so you don't mind if a
certain numbers gone lower or higher but
you know why that things gonna lower our
hearts because of this this concept is
true in many aspects of our lives you
could say my lower back is having
problems I really have a hard time with
my lower back and so you go out and work
on your lower back and you hire a
personal trainer said that has nothing
to do with your lower back your
hamstrings are weak your abs are weak
you need to work on your abs and your
hamstring you got to be kidding me say
my marriage is not working out it's
because of you know our finances because
it is you go talk to somebody and they
say no it's because of communication you
know my finances are not working outs
because of my income no it's because
you're spending too much money with the
barbecues you do every other weekend a
beer you're spending 300 bucks every
time that $600 right there but once you
figure out why it is that you're having
those challenges you're having and you
make minor little tweaks here and there
you start really enjoying the game of
life and it just becomes so effortless
to you and you know who could do that
anybody you just got to figure out what
those tweaks are they need to make its
my message of the week to know please be
sure to subscribe and share this video
you